okay it's been a little while since I
did this and people have been emailing
so let's do it
put down your phone grab a book and read
something okay I'm gonna give you three
book recommendations today you can of
course find all of my recommendations at
david pakman.com slash recommendations
and if you use the links there to buy
any of these books or any of the books
that are already on there we get a
little bit of a slice a slice of your
amazon transaction okay i've got two
non-fiction books for you and then a
fiction book first a nonfiction book
just read this last week very very quick
read very interesting the book is
thinking in bets by Annie Duke Annie
Duke is both a poker player and a sort
of business consultant and thinking in
bets is a very interesting book for me
as someone in politics because we deal
very often with beliefs and so often
conversations and politics are this is
true or that's not true and in reality
even when we say those things typically
what we're doing is we're we're
assessing the probability that something
is true we have some level of confidence
that something is true that is greater
than zero but less than 100 and what
Annie Duke very interestingly does and
in a way that with a lot of interesting
stories and anecdotes and examples is
she says we would benefit from thinking
in bets when we think about our views
and decisions that we are making so much
like I said in the last segment if you
told me I need to make a bet about is
Michael Bloomberg or Amy Klobuchar more
likely to be the nominee there's a
certain amount of money that I'd be
willing to bet based on what the return
would be and this is where the idea of
you know even money odds and betting
comes from when you have odds
you might bet on something that is very
unlikely if the reward feels in
proportion to how unlikely it is so the
book talks a lot about you know when we
say clearly the clearly the the ice caps
melting are a sign of climate change we
are really dealing in a
estimate of how likely we believe that
to be and when you say to me are you
100% sure about this that or the other
thing about climate change no not a
hundred percent sure but I'm sure enough
that I wouldn't bet against it and that
is exactly the framework that Annie Duke
talks about and says in conversation we
would also be much more open to other
ideas if the conversations are less
about I believe a you believe the
opposite of a and more about will I
believe this with 70% probability you
seem to believe it only with 40%
probability let's figure out where the
difference comes in and let's figure out
what level of risk or what level of loss
we are willing to accept very important
political applications to the idea of
thinking and bets so that's thinking and
bets by Annie Duke completely different
type of book I'm about three-quarters of
the way through this one how to lie with
maps by Markman Monnier
I recommend it to you I think it's
called how to lie with statistics some
years ago by I believe the author's last
name is huff and that is a classic old
book I think it might even be from the
it might be the 50s might be the 70s it
is a great book that tells you how we
should apply a skeptical eye to
statistics in scientific studies in
advertising in commercials in news
reports this is the more academic
equivalent of that specifically with
maps and graphical representations of
data so the book very clearly explains
with examples how you can use visual
representations of data and maps to
further your political propaganda goals
how at the local level maps can be used
you know to try to get the Zoning Board
to approve your swimming pool or
whatever the case may be maybe less
relevant globally but still important to
understand when it comes to climate
really important ways that maps can be
used to distort when it comes to as many
of you know when you have a globe when
you have a spherical earth and you try
to map that earth onto a piece of paper
onto something flat
you have to somehow account for the fact
that you're taking a sphere and
flattening it out and the ways in which
one chooses to do that have very
different implications about political
power about geography and so many
different things all of that and things
that I just haven't gotten to yet
because I'm only 3/4 of the way through
the book is discussed in this book how
to lie with maps by mark Mon Mon EA
check it out very good one highly
recommended all right lastly today here
is a fiction recommendation there are
people in my audience who love the
author Neil Stevenson I read a lot of
his work he wrote Snow Crash which is a
book emblematic of the cyberpunk genre
he wrote zodiac a sort of eco thriller
that takes place in Boston he's written
a lot of really really great books I've
had his book Anna thumb for a while and
have not yet read it because I just
couldn't I didn't feel ready to make
like the nine hundred or thousand page
commitment I have started reading his
book fall and I plan to read this one is
like 900 pages I planned to read just
the first couple hundred pages and then
put it down I'm about 600 pages in and
the book is fantastic it is a journey
through a long period of time it is a
story about in a sense the digitizing of
our human consciousness the characters
are extraordinarily interesting the
writing as always by Neal Stephenson is
extraordinary it is a commitment I'm
about 600 pages in this is fall or dodge
in hell
that's the the full title of the book
Neal Stephenson if you've read anything
by him I recommend this if you liked any
of the other things we've read by him if
you've never read anything by Neal
Stephenson I don't know that I start
with fall I probably start with Snow
Crash or zodiac or seven Eve's
but I could not recommend this more
highly it is a journey it is a journey
through time and space the likes of
which only Neil Stevenson can weave
together so there's three
recommendations for you find all of
these and more at david pakman.com slash
reckon
and Asians